a lot of people thought that a new valon
agent had been leaked the abilities
looked real the name is believable but
we may all been quite possibly
hood-winked tricked and bamboozled by a
single person and when you see how they
may have done it you gotta say well
played
guys i moved out i'm alone i'm single
but in order for me to keep the lights
on you gotta hit that like button that
subscribe button and bring that
notification bell for me there is
something to be said about the ballerina
community
we are creative from cleversage wall
setups to inventive sofa dart lineups
something i personally really like to
look at are concept agents that aren't
in the game yet but could be like this
one or this one all of this keeps me
really foaming at the mouth for new
agent concepts because personally i am
sick and tired of the chamber meta so
when this agent leak was posted onto
reddit i got really excited i mean just
look at these abilities bubble e equip
bubble and enter into a phased state to
play some a bubble by pressing the
ability key activate to create an
impenetrable bubble bullets cannot pass
through tartarus pit q equip a tartarus
charger fire to launch a crippling shot
that deals some damage and slows players
within the zone vision taker c equip a
distortion wall launcher fire to create
a small line of distortion enemies will
get briefly blinded if they walk through
and finally golem x equip the golem doll
fire to throw the golem doll all
teammates in the radius will get a
regeneration buff and enemies will get a
dk buff lasts for a duration or until
destroyed by enemies the abilities
looked like a great support agent and it
got the community talking about the good
and the bad that could come with the
agent at the time i personally thought
that the tartarus pit was just like a
hybrid combination of chambers deagle
and auto snipe which like
all right but the golem that was pretty
cool becca said you and your teammates
up for some really cool pushes my mind
immediately went to a split i was kinda
excited and it wasn't just me either the
whole community began to discuss the new
agent abilities there were even people
making jokes about how to stop any leaks
from happening again in this video we
gotta break down the new mage controller
leaks because all the abilities got
revealed and uh they got leaked pretty
early and they're freaking nuts this is
gonna be an incredible character that is
going to change the meta i promise you
that and this morning on the valerian
subreddit we had a screenshot leak that
supposedly is mage's abilities now take
this with a grain of salt but we'll go
over them real quick now of course after
we stopped fawning over the agent
abilities we began to think critically
would this be viable in a ranked how
this affects pro play well i'm glad we
didn't spend too much time discussing
all of that because as it turns out this
whole leak
wasn't actually real that's right the
whole thing from the abilities their
description and icons seem to have been
completely fabricated now normally when
fake leaks like this happen we don't get
to hear from their mysterious creators
but in this case this fake was claimed
by a tick-tocker known as valo leaker
they uploaded tick-tock explaining in
detail how they in their own words
trolled the whole valorant community i
started with creating icons for mage i
just messed around until it looked good
enough i used other ability icons as a
reference to help design everything so
this person claims that they use the
other agent's icons and abilities as
reference points which we could presume
is so they could make their creation
look the most believable then they said
they used cypress ability screens some
photoshop skills and the right enough
font to create their masterpiece i
thought to myself why not post on reddit
see how far i can go
in the first 48 hours the post got over
half a million views with a 97 percent
upload rate were we trolled it looks
like it but there's always the
possibility that this person is faking
being the faker but it got the community
talking once again with a bunch of
people claiming that they never even
believed it in the first place
personally for me looking back on the
abilities if you look at the specific
grammar of the sentences
little obvious that it's a fake no
copywriter will let that through so yeah
while we can't say for sure that this
was the person who did it let's talk
about something through various valorem
lore keepers if you will there actually
may be new voice lines alluding to a new
agent within the pbe
i know we're all feeling hurt and
confused with all this fake stuff but
just like trust me on this one this one
seems legit so this isn't live content
but it very well may be just take a
listen the fugitive was here so was
realm it was definitely a firefight that
is not the only evidence we have
pointing to a new agent different emails
and lore trinkets have been posted that
some have concluded could be pointing to
a new agent coming out in the future it
is believed that the new agent is indian
and is named varun batra so we have
solid evidence in the form of lore that
riot will be releasing a new agent soon
if you can remember this is what they
did with fade remember those little
email tablets that were sitting in our
spawns for a little bit and were vaguely
threatening our heroes and the emails
that you could find in the range that
was fade now she is a stellar initiator
that you've seen many ranked and
professional games so it's not
unreasonable to believe that the lore
that may be dropped is referring to the
next agent maybe that's why some of us
were so quick to believe this leak riot
have set somewhat of a precedent in
teasing their agents before they release
them personally i also think that we are
desperate for repeat from the chamber
meta and will take anything that can
stop him like an impenetrable bubble in
the meantime it looks like we'll just
have to wait and see what these new
agent abilities are the only thing i ask
is that riot brings some chamber nerfs
along with them
listen of the end board though valerian
does have really cool lore it's like
super cool and they work super hard on
it and it's super easy to digest i think
everyone should be paying attention to
it if you're not
[Music]
uh it's rough buddy i don't know you
should
[Music]
turret out